no big deal my sis the creator of the
year I mean this is a huge moment for
you this is like this is like so big
it's like the biggest moment my life
it's like not even I'm just one of my
fans like it's like what a hundred
percent like I know this is like so
quintessentially me like almost crying
apology I'm so thankful for my fans but
like this is all them like I just every
video I've ever made I've never looked
at myself as the creator of the year I
still like I don't like I'm just like a
girl making videos living her life and I
just like I'm so grateful even I
remember your reaction when you found
out you were even nominated you couldn't
even believe that I literally was like
this is a joke this is a lie this is a
prank I like I'm gonna go get my order
right now like I'm I was it last year
that you accepted for shame yeah that's
that's what a full circle moment for you
this is the most full circle moment of
my my entire life 100% like a year ago
today like I walked on stage holding
James Award and I said I will never be
this I will never have this I know none
of you ever thought I'd be holding a
sword looking back at this year I mean
you really have accomplished so much you
have taken over so many different
avenues you've become this pop-culture
phenomenon what are you most proud of
when you look back at this past year the
moments I had found in the moments I
were happy at 100% like the the
authentic moments where I was having
with the people that I loved no matter
what there's there's so many things that
I worked on that I'm really proud of
this year but connecting with my fans
and just like being myself is always the
thing that I'm like the most proud of
like being able to make them like laugh
or smile or forget about whatever's
going on in their lives for even a
second and now this I can't believe I'm
closing out 2019 like this thank you
guys to anybody and how are you gonna
celebrate when you get home tonight
obviously I'm sure as Jake texted yeah
he was gonna be so must be so proud of
you literally was just messaging
here my creative the year no matter what
and I was like damn I like I was
literally like thank you I love you
that's what means the most to me cuz I'm
not gonna win
so it's it's weird I'm gonna spend
tonight sobbing I I feel so out of body
right now I'm losing it's so crazy I
remember last year at the streamys we
were saying how this is gonna be the
year of Tana 2.0 in 2019 and you have
just accomplished so much you have come
so far and you are working so hard and
you deserve it you deserve to be creator
of the year thank you so so so so so
much I feel like career-wise I did a lot
of crazy is here all with the help of my
incredible fans my literal family and I
just I just want 2019 I want 2019 to end
with us really thinking about mental
health and taking care of ourselves and
being authentic in 2020 and I'm just
excited for that I don't know yeah how
witty well how do you beat a year like
this in 2020 that is not gonna be
something by sleeping and getting Sarah
believe and avoiding the paparazzi no
I'm kidding I don't know that this has
been one of the craziest years of my
life but I'm just excited for what's to
come 100% Congrats on everything since
I'm so happy for you you're killing it
[Music]